Here are the equations for each of the pieces of our line over here. The first
one was pretty easy to figure out, it's just y equals 0. Since this is just a
horizontal line at well, y equals 0. For each of these other three equations, I
started out using point-slope form and then transformed to have equations in
slope-intercept form. Over here on the graph, I wrote the tax rates
corresponding to each of the brackets to make reminding myself of the slope of
each line really easy. Then I just picked a point for each line that was easy
to identify. Plugging in all of that information gave us these equations. For
the lowest bracket, we have y equals 0.1x minus 500. For the middle one we have
y equals 0.2x minus 2000. And for the highest bracket, or at least the highest
one shown here, we have y equals 0.3x minus 5500.